c'est ici à la base nautique vie chère
aura lieu le 10 juin 2018
le top départ dit taurel mal premier
triathlon xl de la région centre a pour
signer dit parent de soi toumy degham
triathlète tourangeau élite
multimédaillé sacré récemment champion
de france militaire pour les 3 km de
nage l'organisation a opté pour deux
boucles d'un kilomètre 9 avec une sortie
à l'australienne un choix stratégique
c'est facile par rapport à la gestion de
l'effort parce que l'on fait il ya deux
boucles on sait quand on ressort on est
à la mi course
donc on peut un petit peu géré l'effort
et ça permet aussi de connaître des
états parce que comme une fac à
l'australienne ont peur de l'eau on a à
peu près 40 mètres à faire sur le sol et
là on peut entendre les écarts des
entraîneurs ou des amis de la famille
une boucle également pour les 180 km de
vélo spectacle pour les familles le
touran monde se veut accessible et
touristique pour les participants ne pas
retrouver le démarrera du parc expo de
tourtouse un garage avait loupé couvert
pour se diriger vers l'ouest jusqu'au
château de villandry avec un demi tour
au niveau du circuit nascar
on a voulu mettre en valeur la vallée de
la loire et fédéraux qui ont un très bon
revêtement un parcours plat assez facile
ce qui permettra aussi de aux novices
pour ceux qui n'ont jamais fait
d'ailleurs iman enfin de création et
celle ci celle de faire leurs premiers
sur un parcours de foi relativement
accessible le parcours du marathon reste
encore à préciser mais les 600
participants attendus côtoieront les
berges du plan d'eau des peuples réédit
lac de labarre jaune riz événement
ouvert au 560 licencier 17 clubs de
triathlon d'indre-et-loire espère
surtout attirer les sportifs amateurs à
la conquête de nouveaux défis